it was a very gruesome Super Tuesday for
the progressive movement in the United
States one of the things I do not do on
this program I will not do on this
program is give you unrealistic
assessments of how things are going and
I told you yesterday the momentum for
Joe Biden from his over-performing in
South Carolina
combined with the drop out and
endorsements of Pete Budaj edge and Amy
Klobuchar it is likely to propel Biden
to better results than the polling
reflects going in to yesterday's
elections and this indeed happened it
was a bad night for Bernie Sanders it
was about as good of a night as Joe
Biden could have hoped to have given
where he was just a week ago even
winning in Texas was Joe Biden which he
was not expected to win so we're going
to look at the results we're going to
look at how the results compared with
the polls we'll look at the delegate
numbers we'll analyse the path forward
but what is really important to
understand bigger picture about what's
going on here is that this has been a
similar pattern in the last several
Democratic primaries where we're going
to look at this tomorrow in 2008 and in
2016 you have a situation where you have
the polling at the beginning of the
primary and then things start to
drastically shift either two candidates
getting very very far apart and then it
reverses or two candidates getting very
very close and then it reverses look at
2008 and look at 2016 and look in 10
days at 2020 and you will see a very
similar pattern and again being
surprised when the same patterns repeat
themselves means we're not paying
attention we are being adults here we
are going to deal with what is and not
what we would like to be let's start
with the results there were 14 primaries
yesterday plus American Samoa Joe Biden
won nine of the primaries Bernie won
four and they're still counting in Maine
which is very close it's within a point
right now but with 24 delegates the
results there are only going to
influence the total count to some degree
it's going to be you know a a
a fraction of marginal difference there
Joe Biden winning in Alabama Virginia
North Carolina Tennessee Arkansas
Oklahoma Minnesota Massachusetts and
Texas Bernie Sanders winning Vermont
Colorado Utah and California although
the exact margin they're still being
tallied and then as I mentioned in Maine
in Maine the counting is still going on
Michael Bloomberg did pick up delegates
he is now in a third / fourth place in
delegate numbers based on active active
candidates we will discuss that
Elizabeth Warren did very poorly
performing at the 20% level only in her
home state of Massachusetts where she
came in third place and much like
Michael Bloomberg Warren clearly has no
path to the nomination at this point in
time when she gets out he's increasingly
a topic of concern says she's fighting
on to the following primaries based on a
fundraising email that she sent although
at the same time there is the idea that
she is reevaluating the campaign as is
Michael Bloomberg let's now look at the
delegate numbers every website has
slightly different numbers on this but
as of right now according to the
Associated Press the delegate count is
Biden four five three and Bernie three
eight two that's a 70 one delegate lead
for Joe Biden and we'll we'll discuss in
a moment why that is important and then
you see Warren and Michael Bloomberg
50th and 44th place 50 delegates and 44
delegates respectively one thing I was
paying attention to that tells us a lot
about momentum and this is really
entering the analysis of what's to come
because there are a lot of people saying
this is over for Bernie and there are a
lot of people saying this is the
beginning of the fight for Bernie and
there are a lot of Delegates still out
there which is of course completely true
when we look at the polling and compare
it to the results if candidates do
better than the polling it's a signal
that they're carrying pent up momentum
with them including into future
elections and that's what we need to
look at and when we compare the results
to the polling what you see are good
furs for Joe Biden again I'm just the
messenger if you look at many of these
States Joe Biden won by a larger margin
than the polling so as an example in
Alabama Biden won by 47 he was projected
to win by 25 Biden overperformed the
polls by 22 Arkansas Biden overperformed
by five California where Bernie won
Bernie underperformed by three in
Colorado where Bernie won Bernie
underperformed by one Massachusetts
Warren and Bernie were slated to to win
one or the other
Biden won by seven over-performing
everything if you look at for example
Minnesota a Biden was supposed to lose
by five he won by nine that's a plus 14
and as you go down the list you find
that Biden overperformed basically every
state and Bernie underperformed
basically every state even Utah and
Vermont where Bernie won underperformed
the polls by 8 and by 12 so the numbers
are not particularly good for Bernie
Sanders sometimes when you look forward
you have to look at what regions are
left to vote so let's talk about that
going forward yes there are plenty of
Delegates out there yes 71 delegates as
a margin Bernie Sanders could have very
easily overcome in just one night of
voting but the question is where is it
going to happen and there are all sorts
of hot takes about this it's not over
Bernie's in it and they're absolutely
right Bernie can win it but the window
closes unless we can figure out exactly
where Bernie can win it because if you
add up the momentum meaning a lot of
people saw Joe Biden's reversal
yesterday and I predict Biden's support
will only grow from this point forward
too if you look at the remaining big
states they are not good states for
Bernie Sanders example Florida has Biden
plus 22 and that's 219 delegates that's
a real problem for Bernie unless he
reverses it New York is going to be
closer for sure there's no recent
polling but it could be roughly a
three-way split between Biden and Bernie
and Bloomberg if Bloomberg gets out
Biden likely wins New York but again if
it's a roughly even split that helps
Biden in the delegate math because it
just maintains his lead we look at
Michigan the latest poll in Michigan has
Biden ahead Georgia is a big one with a
hundred and five delegates and Biden's
been ahead there since day one there's a
question mark around Ohio we don't have
any recent polls there and lastly if
Bloomberg does get out and Warren does
not he's reportedly reevaluating his
campaign today it's not clear what Biden
is doing if Bloomberg's out and Warren's
in that is even more support that's
going to go from Bloomberg to Biden and
that could be the nail in Bernie's
coffin that's the way the numbers are
looking right now so I'm here to tell
you
Bernie has a path and it is a steep
uphill path and it's getting to be very
similar to in 2016 and what I don't want
to participate in are these completely
out-of-this-world hypotheticals where
you had I'm not even gonna name the
people a lot of them don't even really
have shows anymore their online presence
has gone away anyway so you wouldn't
even recognize the names but they were
there were all sorts of people in 2016
when it was very clear that it was over
for Bernie insisting not only that
Bernie had a shot but the Bernie had the
most likely shot I'm not going to do
that this is bad for Bernie he has a
path it depends on a reversal of
momentum it depends on changes happening
in the dynamics for this race this is
always a tough situation it happened in
2016 as well when I can't in good faith
come to you and tell you lies or blow
smoke up your whatever when I do I am
not a campaign spokesperson right this
is a well-orchestrated reversal by the
Democratic Party it took 96 hours to
rock it Joe Biden into the position of
now being the favorite to win this thing
and the important thing that I want to
get into because with the numbers are
the numbers and I'm telling you what
they are the polls in upcoming states
are what they are
what I want to talk about is should this
be considered a wake-up call to the
progressive movement and if so what kind
and that's what I want to talk about
next if you ever feel like you just
don't have enough time to read all the
books you want to read you have to check
out one of my favorite apps called
blinka splink a-- stakes thousands of
popular nonfiction books and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book just
imagine how you'll be able to expand
your horizons and knowledge by being
able to soak up all of the important
insights from ten different books in an
afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video